There's an easy way to answer this question experimentally,
which is just to construct the set where it's a list with each element as the object
that you're constructing a set from, and what you find is that it's possible to construct a set
where 101 is an element, where hash browns--the string is an element.
If you try to construct a set where a set is an element, that's an error,
and that's an error because it's not a hashable object.
We'll talk more about that next. We can construct a set where an element is a topple.
We haven't actually talked about topples yet in CS101, but this is something that you've actually use
when you return to your values from a procedure that's what's going on.
It's like a list but it's immutable.
You could figure out experimentally that that's hashable or you could do searches to find out why,
and finally perhaps the most surprising one is that you can construct a set where an object in it is set.
Set by itself is actually a type, which itself is an immutable object.
This question involve lots of things that you might not have learned about yet,
certainly lots of things we didn't cover in CS101,
but the point of the quiz is to see that well you can do experiments and you can do research
using the documentation to answer these questions yourself.
Let's go get how you might have done that.